-We're hanging out with the one
and only Drew Barrymore!
Drew --
Oh, lookit, I love it.
Come on. The greatest.
♪♪
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Drew, we're a few months
into the new year,
and you told me that
your mantra for this year,
2022, is the Year of Know --
K-N-O-W.
-That's right -- Year of Know.
-The Year of Know.
What does this mean?
-Like Carson, Kreskin.
-Yeah.
Kreskin, yeah.
-Oh, the best.
-Yeah.
-Last year was
the Year of Less.
-You want less of things.
-Yes, I'm very maximalist,
gluttonous, live in extremes,
big personality --
nuts, you know, a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
And -- But a student of life,
always working on myself,
and every day,
I get a little bit better,
hopefully.
-Yeah.
-And so I thought,
"What if I took this year,
as, you know,
just trying to be really aware
of everything I'm learning?"
I feel like we're constantly --
I'm constantly one step forward,
a step back.
And I just thought
if I could have more confidence
in what I know.
And I don't know about you guys,
but my inner dialog is not kind,
and I would never speak or treat
anyone the way I treat myself.
And knowing that,
that's the Year of Know --
knowing things, recognizing it.
Even if you're
going on a date with someone,
we all kind of hard launch,
and, like,
"What is the future
going to bring?"
Just enjoy things.
Don't worry about the future
and the past.
Everyone says,
"Try to be present,
try to have balance."
I get so irritated
when they talk like that,
but maybe they're right, so...
-That that makes you
more irritated.
-Yes, which is even more
patronizing and annoying.
-Gosh, yeah.
-So I'm like,
"Instead of the year
of running around
like the crazy headless chicken,
what if I try to act
like this year
that everything I learn
is something I can truly keep,
and the knowledge is there,
and just have
a little more faith in myself?"
-Love this.
This is fantastic.
I love that you do that.
I mean, you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The one thing -- another great
thing about the show is,
you really just put yourself
out there, and a good example,
I remember you had the cast
of "Queer Eye" come on...
-Oh, my God.
It changed my life.
-...and do a makeover for you
and had you do
an actual live date.
-Yes.
-And you filmed it,
and you showed
you going on a live Zoom date.
-Yeah, which I thought the idea
of a Zoom date was, like,
"How on Earth...?"
I don't know why, but --
I'm so IRL.
You know what I mean?
-In real life.
Yeah, you're so IRL.
-I'm so IRL that I was like,
"There's no way..."
-"I mean, totally be IRL!"
-"...I will like a Zoom date."
-"I know!
A 'Zuhm dut.'"
-I -- I -- I -- I tried it.
It turns out it's not as
prophylactic weird as it seems.
I guess we're all
sort of, kind of --
This is the new normal.
The water's out of the bottle.
It's not going back in.
It's dating apps and Zooms,
and maybe you can look at it
as a positive of a screener
or a time-saver.
I don't know.
I still want to meet someone
the old-fashioned way.
-Right?
-I want to --
You know,
I wrote, actually, a paper
that I'm gonna put on my blog
because I love writing
and I have a blog
and I've written books,
and sometimes
you just get inspired.
And I -- I walked up to a guy
in a park, and I was like,
"Are you single?"
[ Laughter ]
And...
-Did his brain explode
out of his head?
-And he was like, "Perhaps,"
and I said,
"Well, that's not 'no.'"
[ Laughter ]
-So...
-"I'll take 'perhaps.'"
-And then I was like,
"Are you gay?"
Because I also
always bark up the wrong tree.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"No, I'm not."
And then we got to talking,
and we had such a good laugh
and such a lovely talk.
And then I was like,
"Ooh, I think I forgot
to ask you
a very important question.
How old are you?"
-Oh.
-And he was like, "28,"
and I was like, "Oh, no!"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, no!"
-Oh, come on.
-And I was like,
"I don't mean this rudely.
You look so much older."
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"It's funny because it's a joke
amongst my friends.
They all -- We --
It's a joke in my life.
I look much older."
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "You do."
"We had a great afternoon.
Have a great life, bud."
-And I just said, "Okay.
That was so fun,
and thank you so much."
We had a great conversation.
And we didn't bother
with the obligatory, like,
"Let's exchange numbers,"
and I just said, "Great."
I said, "I got to tell you,
I just wanted to do something
that I could make
myself proud today,"
and he goes, "I'm proud of you."
[ Applause ]
And I was like, "Thanks."
-Fantastic.
"We got to hang out more."
-And we walked away, and it was
the most positive experience.
I want to do it again.
Was it dating apps
that stopped us
from going up to people
and asking them out?
Now we don't have to worry
about public rejection?
We can just hide behind the app?
Forget it. I'm over it.
I want to --
I want to talk to people IRL.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
One at a time,
let's go through the audience.
Who want -- No.
[ Laughter ]
I wanted to see --
Speaking of
doing something again,
you did something on your show.
You do a thing called
"Drewth or Dare"
every now and then.
-At the end of every show.
Segment seven, on our way out.
-"Drewth or Dare."
-You did one...
-And I'll do anything.
-...and it made me laugh.
And it was --
Here was the dare -- try to eat
a lemon wedge and not react.
-Yeah.
-Now people have been doing this
online, it's on TikTok.
It is called the Lemon Challenge
or something.
Let's do it 'cause I want
to start a movement,
because I was shocked
to find out
how much I suck at this.
-All right,
so just grab a wedge,
and we'll go for it.
This is the Lemon Challenge.
-And have you ever done it?
-Never.
-Okay.
-I'm gonna try to pretend
I am fine.
-Okay, great, good.
-Like, big deal -- it's a lemon.
-Let's do this.
-Yeah, of course.
Cheers, bud.
Awesome.
-Cheers!
-Cheers.
Nice to see ya.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's just sour.
It's just so --
It was good
at the beginning part.
-And by the way,
these are good lemons.
This is a quality lemon here.
-It is a decent lemon
right there.
Just going for it.
Come on, that's a trooper.
Drew Barrymore, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go to DrewBarrymore.com
for more info
on "The Drew Barrymore Show."